Cruises like 15 he got braces. Sure.
It was like, Yo, what are you doing?
They came in, he's like, you don't
have my bat. Also changed his voice.
Do you remember where I did he do that?
He went with veneers. They're brilliant.
They're so good. Years are amazing.
That's what I'm saying Bro. Amazing.
I had a friend,
she did it.
One of the girls that I did news radio
with almost hit her name and I'll get us
a three for one deal up in a forefront.
One Jamie, you want to your lungs.
If you look at the the good ones,
you're like God damn you teeth.
Her fucking fantastic here. That
Bam Tom Cruise. What? Look what?
I don't know if that is veneers or
braces come cause he did wear braces.
Look at real teeth to look at the left.
I think there is real teeth and I
think the one on the left is just,
it could be photoshopped.
I don't remember them being that bad.
I think it's Photoshop. Yeah, see
that's why he's wearing braces.
Teeth are real ta do.
I think those are his real teeth.
Go to him before braces seem to go to him.
Go to him smiling in the color of money
cause he was really young in that movie.
Taco Tom Cruise, color of money, smiling.
She's such a beast than me.
Tom Cruise is a monster.
I just watched the color of money on a
flight. It was fucking crazy right there.
The far left, far left. Holy Shit.
Yeah, those are his teeth, bro.
He just gathers those frontline.
Those front ones have been knocked out and
those, those are fake. Well, there's no,
no, this is a long time ago, man.
This is, this is the color of money.
This is like 1986 yeah.
I'm saying the rest of the teeth or
the color yellow in the middle ones are
white, but that's hard to tell. You
seem dark shadows all over the place.
You can't really gauge yellow right there.
Look at that. It's so hard to judge,
but see his teeth look like that.
I seen all this buddies, gentlemen,
you can't even see his right eye.
You're judging whether or
not that's his teeth color.
You literally can't see his right
eye because he's in so much shafts.
Teeth don't look super suspect.
You know they look like teeth right there.
You crazy. That's his teeth. His
teeth are normal. His teeth were,
you're judging by today's standards.
That's the problem.
Make those teeth perfect like that dude.
If you had bad teeth back then,
if you had fake teeth, they look
fake as fuck. That's true. His teeth,
his teeth were off center like
you know the middle teeth.
They were all kind of pushed over to the,
right.
Now they're way better than [inaudible]
and crooked 56 still doing action movies.
Still does his own stunts,
jumps from building to building
breaks his ankle and filming.
Have you seen that shit? No.
Apparently it's mission impossible.
Movie is a motherfucker and he's
killing it. They said it's killing it.
It's awesome. Mission possible
yet here and it's fantastic.
He's awesome. He's, he's just really
started fuck. But he's awesome.
He's also nice. His Shit. You
know what else, dude? He's,
he was, because watch this,
he jumps off this and breaks his ankle
and he really did all his own stunts.
The watch when he lands. Watch how Jack
does apple get out. Boom. All fucked up.
You ain't ready for that be you
want to be a worldwide action here?
I can't do that. I'll look at
it. I showed hits. What I it is,
I don't quite make it.
Snapper Rooney, stocky
Dick to the metal. He still
finishing. He still finishes. Look,
he's still jumped over the top steel and
seen oiling character Lam that concrete
into his dick bone. And look how he
pulled off. He hobbled off when he got up.
That's why you have to have a stunt
man cause you're going to get,
you guys are hardcore man,
but he likes everything.
He does all the car driving
stunts. Exactly. The
helicopter does all that shit.
I didn't know that. I didn't know he
home blood and look up your tongue.
I don't have to look up shit.
Don't as a free country.
He might have a a dark wish for the
end to one of those movies. Oh my God.
He might have a dark, which might
be right. I have, I have friends.
People discredit it and
because the Scientology stuff,
absolutely 100% do and
Burlison the Scientology thing
is just how he gets by is
a lot of people that have their own
ideologies. They believe it or not,
it might be radical left ideology.
There's a lot of conservative former
like actors that are like super
conservative. They're on Twitter. Like
they're in it. They're in a cult, correct?
Correct. They're all rat. Everyone's
wrapped up in this own little thing.
His thing is just crazy. It's fucked by
a guy who was a science fiction author,
a war, a fucking captains coat on with
a bunch of medals he gave himself,
but they have some legit buildings.
You driven by the Hollywood actors.
They have legit actress, man.
Dude, Tom Cruise is fucking legit.
John Travolta has done
some silly nonsense,
but he's also done pulp fucking fashion.
He did carry when he was like really
good at Saturday night live face off.
He's a very fit and active as
a terrible movie face off. Oh,
that's a great one.
When they cut the face off and put
it on the other person has happened.
Post structure magically changes and
nick cage looks like John Travolta,
Tom [inaudible] technologies,
not terrorist debt.
There's no way Bro.
Okay.
What did it happen if Brian
Topp and put it on you?
I would think people were like,
there's a monster here.
First of all,
you head's way bigger.
So your skin a bit like some
60 year old lady from Bel Air.
So those 60 year old ladies where their
mouth looks like it's so big and key
your head,
cause they've been pulling,
they're pulling their skin back
to their mouth as like a joker.
They lose fat in their face.
As you get older, your memory,
you used to make fun of me for taking
an acting class and I stayed in 19 last
for eight years longer than I needed to
because I love of train wreck and these
two guys did a c Jeffrey
tambor was teaching and these
two guys did a scene from
faceoff and the curtain comes up and,
and one guy's hanging from a chain and
the other guy's torturing him and it's
like, and then he goes, yeah. And so,
and he's hitting him and it's crazy.
And at the end of the scenes like scene,
everybody's like,
and Jeffrey tambor just takes a
sip of his coffee and he goes,
what was that scene? And the
guy was face off, face off.
What is that? It's a movie.
It's an action movie.
John Travolta in an occasion
that seen as band forever.
That was it. Moving man. Yeah, whatever.
I heard this gaudy movie's terrible.
It's like doors moves all the time.
I've heard it already. Yeah.
It was like a zoo. Good tomato.
Why aren't I saw the, I saw the
trailer and I got into it. Okay, let's,
let's just Google. How bad
is the God he movie? It's,
I mean there was it say
two out of 10 that is insane. Okay,
that's great. Is that has to be correct?
He's great. He looks good. He
looks like a bomb. He looks good.
He looks like a good God.
He John's fault.
Is j Simpson on FX played a
shipper. That's right. Yeah,
that's right. He's a great, he's a great
actor and he's created everything man.
He just does a lot of
bad movies. Yeah, shorty.
He just does his and has
done a lot of bad movies.
I know Tom Cruise is
done from end of days.
Even like all those movies didn't even do.
I love them to know this guy is
fucking fantastic. Was best movie.
You know what else is good with that?
What is the,
is that the one the tomorrow again,
he dies. He keeps dying. That's it.
Does that end of days? That's no,
I'm thinking of a different one.
He did like two science fiction movies.
I'm thinking of director tomorrow. Yes.
That was what it was called, but it was
called edge of tomorrow. Originally,
and then like we've talked about this
before, they change. That's right.
Because the marketing,
because it came out and you kissed her
original marketing was edge of tomorrow,
whatever the fuck it came out.
And then people are like,
God that no one showed up to it.
But the people that went were like,
that's like the greatest movie ever.
So then it started to gain
traction then like, hold up,
we need to relabel this thing. Then they
relabeled it and that movie's fucking,
that might be his best movie.
It's a great fucking mood,
a great fucking science fiction movie.
It is one of the most underrated
science fiction movies ever.
And if you're a [inaudible] fan and
you avoided it just because, oh,
it's a Tom cruise movie. Yeah. You fucked
up because it is amazing. It's amazing.
I did a reading with him one time
and, and uh, he, in the reading,
it was just literally me, him, Eric
Stoltz, Amy smart movie. It was moving,
it never got made called men and I,
I was reading,
I was reading all the parts opposite him
and the wall and they were talking to
Owen Wilson. So I was right next to him
and I, you know, spent, I don't know,
maybe three hours with him and
it was a small, nobody was out.
Nobody else was in the room,
like just Todd Phillips and a couple bags.
He in the reading, like in the
reading as you're just doing it,
acting full out and, and, and
amazing and, and just loves it.
And almost like his eyes were watery
at one point where everything's like,
all the chips are down in the scene.
And then I was just,
this fucking dude is up make,
I kept staring at him and I
believed everything he was
doing and just sitting at
a table and we get there. He's a
little late, just a little late,
profusely apologizes. He's got to,
haven't eaten. Just give me a second.
I'm diamond and he's just talking.
He's so nice.
And he had five pieces of Sashimi
with a tiny little pepper on each one.
And some Penta water and he
was like, thank you so much.
It was great. Boom, boom,
boom. And then we went
out, read the thing,
and then he wanted to hear what
all of us thought of the script.
What are suggestions were
and when he listens to you,
his eyes sparkle, his mouth moves
in an oh like you can be like,
I think I was a little confused in the
beginning and he's like, Whoa, hold on.
What he, what he, you know, he's
zeroed in on you. And I was like,
this guy loves me man.
We're going to be best friends.
And then yeah,
we dated for it.
We can put you in the mission
and pulse was some shit. I talk,
I spend time with him. Dude,
you're not Scientology. Well,
he could get you to join.
I think he could get you to join. Yeah. I
wouldn't show up. And I'd be like, yeah,
of course he would get mad
that you weren't showing up.
But if you did show up and you charmed
people there and just rub backs,
I know a lot of [inaudible] that you loved
them. I was in the class for 10 years.
That is cited in the book by, uh, in, in,
I'm going clear at that whole class
that, that I was in that class. She,
I remember you had me come to one
of those little boots. Sure did.
Went to an event, a thing that was
going on, watch the guy saying, we, we,
we watched the guys saying,
well,
we were so high and we're in like a
neighboring dimension watching reality
through a dirty mirror in
the Scientology building.
How will to get it to show bare. There
was near there. It was in the theater.
We were barbecued. I mean,
Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, Bubba,
Bubba, Bubba, bubba barbecue,
freaking out watching this,
that they were singing
musicals and it was not good.